this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist use the link in the
description and receive one free week
and 25 off a premium membership
imagine a hallway containing three
different rooms in each room there is a
person being experimented on a captive
subject to a rogue clandestine operation
headed by the world's greatest most
intelligent neuroscientist this
neuroscientist has been contracted by an
intelligence agency group to research
consciousness perception and
intelligence all in an effort to develop
new understandings and technologies
related to the mind
in each room we find brains running
experiments on brains
experiments run on thought
as we enter the hallway we find
ourselves at the first room the door is
closed and locked inside there is a man
named john he is not allowed out and no
one is allowed in he has been completely
isolated for some time provided food and
water through a contactless delivery
system
a woman who works at the lab has now
recently been instructed to begin
periodically communicating with john by
slipping him notes under his door
she has not told anything else she does
not know who is in the room or why
one morning after she begins following
this instruction john wakes up to a note
in his room he is both immediately
curious and hopeful of what it might say
however to great disappointment when he
picks it up to read it he finds that it
is written in chinese a language he does
not know at all
however john quickly notices that now
also placed in his room are boxes full
of papers pencils and erasers as well as
books containing comprehensive
instructions for how to appropriately
respond in chinese to statements and
questions the woman might write
in the books john can locate and match
the symbols the woman writes and then
write the relevant corresponding symbols
that the book provides facilitating a
conversation
at first john is confused but desperate
for social interaction he soon engages
with the woman writing back notes
according to the book's instructions
as time passes the woman begins to like
and then fall for john believing she is
communicating with a charismatic man who
was fluent in chinese
of course however john has no idea
what he is saying
in this experiment referred to as the
chinese room we find the following
question being asked
what does it mean to be intelligent
with the advent and rapid development of
digital computing and artificial
intelligence the question concerning
when or if a machine could be considered
intelligent able to think and possess an
understanding is only becoming
increasingly relevant
if john can convince the woman he is
intelligent or fluent in chinese based
on what he outputs from the room but can
do so without ever actually
understanding chinese and what he is
saying then the output of john's
behavior is not sufficient in qualifying
him as intelligent or in this case
possessing an actual understanding of
what he is saying
and so likewise if a computer program
can follow syntactic rules well enough
to provide an output that can convince a
person that it is thinking and fully
understanding that does not necessarily
mean that it is
this experiment challenges the
philosophical positions known as
functionalism and computationalism
functionalism arguing that mental states
are to be identified by what they do
rather than by what they are made of and
computationalism arguing that the mind
is an information processing system and
consciousness is merely a form of
computation
according to the chinese rooms
proposition however for intelligence of
mind to actually exist there needs to be
understanding which is inevitably always
missing from a digital computer
this poses the question though what
constitutes understanding
obviously john understanding chinese or
not is essentially binary but can john
still understand what he is doing in the
situation without understanding chinese
in other words does john's understanding
of the fact that he is in taking and
sending out messages in chinese still
constitute some form of understanding on
what level is a computational system
required to understand what it is doing
for it to be considered sufficient
enough for intelligence is it a total
comprehensive understanding that is
required a partial understanding in a
specific way how does one determine this
how does one verify it after all do we
as humans really understand what we mean
even when we know what we are saying
ultimately if the door to john's room
was suddenly opened and the woman saw
john showing emotion and effort as he
wrote his responses down from the
instruction books clearly understanding
not the language but the significance of
it his role in the exchange
would this change things would the woman
still find him worthy of love and
possessing of a sufficient enough
understanding to be intelligent
likewise if a machine functioned as if
it understood behaved as if it did and
made the explicit claim that it felt as
though it did all based on a program's
code do we believe it
how do we treat it
what are the ethics now needed
[Music]
as we move further down the hall in the
next room there's a woman named mary
mary has been contained in this room
ever since she was born completely
closed off from the rest of the world no
one has gone in and she has never been
let out she has been communicated with
exclusively through an intercom system
inside the room there is no color and
there never has been it is completely
black and white
her skin and hair have all been modified
and dyed black white and gray through a
delivery system she has only been given
food and drink completely dyed with
black and white food coloring the only
other things in the room that she has
been given to pass the time are books
and research papers all also in black
and white contained inside the books and
papers is all of the known knowledge on
one subject
color perception without having ever
seen a color in her entire life mary has
become an expert on color
she knows everything there is to know
the physics of it the process by which
different wavelengths of light stimulate
the retina in the eye how it triggers
different electrical signals that affect
neural activity in the brain and how the
brain interprets these signals into
conscious experiences in the forms of
different color perceptions
soon however the door to mary's room
will be opened and she will be let out
for the first time in her life she will
see color first hand
the question this experiment will then
ask is when mary leaves the room will
she learn anything new about color
if she already possesses and understands
all of the known knowledge on color
perception is there still something
unknown to her contained in experiencing
it firsthand via the eye
this experiment referred to as mary's
room attempts to demonstrate what is
known as the knowledge argument which is
the claim that there are truths related
to conscious experience that cannot be
described or known by mere knowledge of
physical facts in other words there is a
property of knowledge and understanding
that can only be found through
first-hand conscious experience which
according to the argument extends beyond
the mere physicality of the experience
this argues against the theory known as
physicalism which is the counter view
that argues that everything in the
universe including mental states is
physical with physical explanations
the belief that mary will experience and
learn something novel when seeing color
for the first time might seem obvious
but if she does
what exactly is it that is new
if the experience is tied to something
physical she at least theoretically
should have already known if it is not
physical what is it is it the mental
state felt by the color but what is
being felt other than the physical state
in the brain that the color produces in
the form of a mental state which again
mary should have or at least could have
already known
if she knows all the characteristics of
a mental state through knowledge
wouldn't she already know how it feels
perhaps then this experiment is and will
remain restricted by the limits of
language and knowledge itself perhaps
rather than any ineffable quality of
subjective conscious experience mary
will demonstrate that language as a
vehicle of thought and understanding is
simply far too limited to get near the
mental state equivalent to first-hand
experience but nonetheless theoretically
with advanced enough language it would
be possible
as we move down to the end of the
hallway in the final room
is you
your brain currently floats in a stasis
tube of nutrient solution wires are
implanted into it and plugged into a
machine that actively processes and
stimulates all of your brain's nerve
impulses
everything you are experiencing right
now is mapped modeled and created by
this machine your brain being stimulated
into sequences of various mental states
that reproduce your regular perceptions
you are not in the world as you think
you are you are not in your body you are
not physically encountering any
environment through any senses your
memory is actively being altered and
updated to create cohesiveness in the
story you imagine about yourself in
order to make this illusion completely
and constantly believable
of course all of these are just thought
experiments but the point of this last
one is to pose the question how can you
know for sure how can you know that all
of the aforementioned the vat the lab
the neuroscientist and so on isn't
actually happening right now and what
you think is happening right now
actually isn't
what can you really know with certainty
to be true can you be certain that
anything exists outside your mind can
you be certain of the nature and
conditions of your mind can you be
certain your senses are not deceiving
you that you are awake and not dreaming
that you are in the real world and not a
simulation or a vat
isn't the only thing you can be certain
of is that you are somewhere somehow in
something existing as a thinking thing
since all your abilities to think and
know occur exclusively inside your mind
there is no way for you to ever step out
of it to know or prove of anything else
[Music]
all of the ideas and questions found in
this hallway of thought experiments the
chinese room created by john searle in
1980 mary's room created by frank
jackson in 1982 and the brain in a vat
created by gilbert harmon in 1973
inspired by rene descartes evil demon
reveal the inherent difficulty of
understanding the mind from within the
mind they reveal how little we truly
know about what makes us who we are they
reveal the potential limits of thought
language and knowledge as vehicles fast
and powerful enough to transcend the
bounds of their origins and perhaps most
beautifully they reveal the brain's
desire and ability to try anyway
to experiment with itself in novel ways
and to use the material of its own
thinking to try to manufacture new
vehicles capable of doing so
of reaching into new realms
of the unknown
this video was sponsored by blinkist
consciousness is an utterly perplexing
place to exist likely ever since the
first brain realized it was a brain it
has long since struggled to make sense
of what this is
of who we are philosophers and
scientists seemingly lack any real
certainty about how and why
consciousness works why does the brain
produce the experience of self is it a
primary function or an emergent property
is consciousness unique to humans if so
why if not how vast is it and how do
physical states in matter produce
subjective personal experiences at all
all of these questions and more are
discussed challenged and responded to in
annika harris's book conscious which you
can find a succinct yet comprehensive
summary of on the book summary app
blinkist blinkist works by condensing
over 5000 books into around 50 minute
summaries that can be read or listened
to perhaps you are interested in
learning about some of the
aforementioned questions but aren't sure
you want to invest the several hours
required into reading the full book
blinkist help solve this problem by
allowing you to explore and discover
meaningful insights from a wide range of
books at a tiny fraction of the time
blinkist has 27 categories to choose
from making it great for just about
anyone's interests if you're interested
in learning more about the mind blinkist
also has many other great titles like
making sense by sam harris being you by
anal seth and the brain by david
eagleman
additionally blankist also has summaries
of popular podcasts as well as complete
audiobooks allowing you to delve even
further into the books and topics you're
interested in all in the same place
if you're interested use the link in the
description and you'll receive one free
week of unlimited access as well as 25
off a premium membership the free seven
day trial can be canceled at any time
within the trial period and of course
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
[Music]
you